charlie morton has appeared three times
against the astros since he left
houston and signed with a raise by a
free agency and in the first
game against him last year he got routed
in houston the second game
uh pardon me let me get this right the
first game was a trampo can of field any
pitch very well
in his first ever start as a ray his
first time back in houston he got routed
and then he played and pitched very well
and got the win against the astros in
game three
of the division series last year so here
is tucker tucker
379 during the postseason without a
homer and he's knocked in four two outs
two on
swing and a miss he struck him out as
tucker goes down
and charlie morton got into a little
trouble and then got himself out of it
junior on the mount for the astros
making his second start this postseason
no decision in game one of the division
series against the a is giving up five
runs four earned
in four plus innings of work so one out
of nobody on for brandon lowe second
baseman and that's a ground ball back to
mccullers fields it down by his left
knee and lobs over to first in plenty of
time and lau is done on one pitch
he's a great fielder and he's got great
quick reactions colors you can tell he
played a lot of shortstop growing up
so runner on with two out for g-man choi
the first baseman
and runner goes pitch is grounded into
the shift fielded by altuve in short
right he throws low to first and guriel
did he drop it
yes he did and choi is aboard wasn't a
great throw by altuve
uriel usually gobbles those up and the
inning continues for the raise on what
will likely be charged as an e4
now here's a chance for margot with two
on and two out in the pitch drives one
into center field
back out of the springer still going
back to the wall it's gone
the rays take advantage of the astros
miscue
and manuel margot in a place he called
home
just hit the rays a three-nothing lead
with a three-run home run
here in the first manuel margot got just
enough and tucked it over the wall in
center field
the rays do indeed take advantage as a
hanging curve ball
ends up over the wall in center field
and we watched jose altuve
and he went down into a crouch after
margaux hit that ball out of the park
it's three-nothing tampa bay early
oh here comes springer representing the
tying run now the 1-1 pitch
there's a swing he popped him up down
the right field line with a stay in play
drifting over margot in the foul
territory near the sidewalk makes the
catch
flips over the wall did he hold on yes
he did what a catch
in right field by manuel margot oh
he had to go over the side railing to
make that grab
huge group of rays went to go check on
their fallen teammate he's uh
walking back a little gingerly but so
far he's been the man of the moment both
offensively and now defensively when we
go
to the home third and dave's right it
sure would be nice to attack on
something here
here's the swing of the ground ball in
the right where second baseman is
waiting and throws again in the dirt
and lao is safe another throwing error
for jose altuve what's going on out
there
he's just aiming it now i mean i'm not
here to say he's got the yips by any
stretch of the imagination but
right there after making the error the
previous time he tried to be as careful
and
as perfect as he possibly could be right
there and just through a warm burner
tampa leading three to nothing breaking
ball it's a ground ball to the right
side out two bay's got it
and a good throw this time to guriel
gets his man and that'll do it for the
raise here in the third
oh the analytic world of baseball the
human element is
a big one and that's why dusty baker
excels as he does look at that sometimes
you just need a hug
and now stringer comes up it's the tying
run it's like this three run lead
charlie keeps
toying with it grounded right there
though is second baseman who juggles
picks it up
goes to first and morton is out of
another jam
and the frustration for the astros
continues to build they leave two men
on in the inning and have left seven for
the game
the one two swing and a miss good change
up down and away
and that is five strikeouts from the
colors one away
curveball drops in for strike three and
lau goes down looking back-to-back case
for mccullers two out swing and a miss
gotta rose arena on the change up and
lance mccullers jr strikes out the side
he has punched out seven today the last
time the astros scored it was an
inning one of yesterday's game they've
gone 13
innings without scoring and correa hits
it in the air pretty deep to
left center field and you can kiss that
one goodbye
into the astros bullpen for correa and
the astros get on the board it's three
to one
tampa bay correa hits his fifth home run
of this postseason boy had been a long
time since the astros were able to score
it's just a matter of time though
burbank is going to stay in and pitch
this inning as well
struck him out fastball up and away at
98 maldonado
is gone for a one down and a seven
struck him out swinging ball in the dirt
cenino picks it up but springer is going
to walk back to the dugout
uncontested there's a three-pitch
strikeout and two men away for fairbanks
in the asteroid
got him swinging on a fastball up and
out of the strike zone and fairbanks
has gotten the raise to the eighth with
the lead and of the last eight hitters
he has struck out
seven of my goodness swings in this one
way up into the air
left center field springer going back to
the pen
it's gone homeron mike cenino with
another october homer
and the rays have a 4-1 lead that ball
was
obliterated and zanino
who really struggled offensively during
the year is helping to carry the offense
in the postseason the astros have loaded
the bases on three straight singles with
nobody out lying down one hop out to
second
lao has it goes to second out throws the
first double flag
will score it's a 4-2 ball game but now
the astros are down to their final out
they swung out and lifted
right center field kierbyer going back
at the track
makes the touch of the race win oh my
everybody exhale 4-2 victory over
houston
and take a two games to none lead